you can be overwhelmed and you can be
underwhelmed can you ever just be
overwhelmed
i think you can in europe right
gabrielle union knows how to pick a
scene partner
the heat is on we're white hot the 48
year old actress shared this hilarious
tick tock on wednesday
where she and step daughter ziya wade
recreate this iconic scene from 10
things i hate about you
i know if you can be overwhelmed and you
can be underwhelmed
but can you ever just be whelmed i think
you can in europe
but in this reimagining gabrielle union
plays
larissa elenix character and ziya takes
on her stepmom's role
tell us you've watched 10 things i hate
about you without telling us
you've watched 10 things i hate about
you we'll start
and you can be overwhelmed and you can
be underwhelmed
can you ever just be overwhelmed i think
you can in europe
right the lol moment follows one of many
amazing tick tocks from gabrielle
she got some help from ziya for the no
hands dance challenge
[Music]
and here's gabrielle's husband dwayne
wade taking a trip to bridgerton
but 10 things isn't gabrielle's only
beloved teen comedy
er it's cold in here i said there must
be some toros in the atmosphere
i know you didn't think a white girl
made that she also recently paid tribute
to her legendary role and bring it on
tell me you watch bring it on without
telling me you've watched bring it on
i'll go first i said burr
it's cold in here there must be some
tauros in the atmosphere
i know you didn't think a white girl may
back up last may et asked gabrielle and
la finest co-star jessica alba
about their next level tick-tock game
and honey i'm surprised you haven't
pulled something with some of the stunts
that you're pulling on tick-tock with
the kids
oh y'all are always up to no good and
you two get
with your tick-tocks and social media
it's just been so nice to have that
sense of entertainment as well
we're both working you know during the
day so by the time our work day is done
and we're able to kind of bond with our
family
you want to do something fun and you
know like we get such a big kick out of
justin
and her family doing their tick tocks
and and we try to learn the dances we
suck as a family we're not we're not as
talented
uh but we try to make it fun and come up
with different things
uh to entertain ourselves and we're like
well if we find this entertaining maybe
other people find it entertaining